Якщо перший рік президентства став для Зеленського своєрідною "учебкою",
коли шоумен набирався політичного досвіду, то впродовж другого року на найвищій державній посаді
у колишнього "Голобородька" вже остаточно спали рожеві окуляри на важливі державні проблеми і процеси.
Чого більше на дворічному балансі Зеленського
з точки зору Європи - провалів чи досягнень?
У перший рік президенства Зеленському вдалося дещо зрушити з місця переговорний процес
щодо окупованого Донбасу. Відбулося декілька хвиль великих обмінів полоненими,
а також, хоч і з порушеннями, більш-менш діяв режим припинення вогню.
Втім, нової ескалації конфлікту уникнути не вдалося. Навесні цього року загроза
російського вторгнення знову здавалася цілком реальною.
Кремль стягнув до кордонів з Україною численні війська, шантажуючи непрямо і Київ, і Захід.
Як вважають опитані DW європейські політики, ця ситуація остаточно продемонструвала Зеленському,
що "просто перестати стріляти", як він колись вважав, недостатньо для мирного врегулювання.
І що попри дипломатичні зусилля з Путіним фактично неможливо домовитися.
Миру досі немає, але це залежить не від України. Це залежить від Кремля.
І, звісно, від здатності Заходу переконати Кремль слідувати тому, про що домовлено,
і виконувати свої зобов’язання. Це дуже непросто.
Хто може переконати Путіна поводитися належним чином, я не знаю. Точно не сама Україна.
Це дуже залежить від адміністрації США, від можливостей ЄС. Звісно, нормандський формат доволі специфічний.
Німеччина і Франція взяли на себе певну відповідальність, але все одно зараз вже виглядає,
що цей формат не здатний забезпечити результати, яких ми очікуємо.
Потрібні нові й більш ефективні ініціативи.
У жовтні минулого року Україна опинилася за крок до фактичного скасування
багатостраждальної антикорупційної реформи. Конституційний суд України визнав
деякі положення антикорупційного законодавства такими, що не відповідають основному закону.
Зокрема кримінальну відповідальність за недостовірне декларування і тим самим, по суті, роботу НАЗК.
Після кількамісячних спроб вирішити цю ситуацію Зеленський вдався до радикального
й юридично суперечливого кроку, скасувавши указ експрезидента Януковича
про призначення Тупицького суддею Конституційного суду.
Колишній президент Румунії, а нині євродепутат Траян Бесеску вважає,
що це був помилковий крок, бо тим самим Зеленський порушив правові процедури.
Незалежність Конституційного суду має захищатися навіть, якщо ми не згодні з рішеннями КС.
Декілька разів я був у ситуації, коли я не погоджувався з рішеннями Конституційного суду Румунії,
але я ніколи не робив таких кроків, які руйнують основи верховенства права.
Це надзвичайно складно з політичної точки зору, але, можливо, Зеленському
слід зробити крок назад у своїй боротьбі з Конституційним судом.
Це буде сигналом, що він хоче миру й об’єднання усіх українських інституцій,
щоб зменшити внутрішні політичні ризики. Це надзвичайно складний момент для України в будь-якому випадку.
Але політичні переговори - це єдине вирішення.
Президент Зеленський має зрозуміти, що бути президентом України не означає мати телешоу.
Це величезна відповідальність.
Водночас, багато інших західних політиків та експертів не такі категоричні і підтримали такий крок Зеленського,
зважаючи на корумпований імідж Конституційного суду.
Адже подібні рішення КС можуть негативно позначитися не лише на боротьбі з корупцією в Україні,
але й на співпраці з ЄС, зокрема щодо безвізу та надання кредитів.
Низка радикальних кроків у кадровій політиці Зеленського засвідчила,
що обіцяну дієву команду "нових обличь" президентові так і не вдалося зібрати.
Ідеться про минулорічну хаотичну заміну урядовців, генпрокурора, очільника митниці
та інших високопосадовців. Нині звільнено ще трьох міністрів.
Але найбільше несприйняття у Європі викликала зміна керівництва "Нафтогазу" - Коболєва на Вітренка.
Адже це, з точки зору Брюсселя, відбулося з порушенням європейських стандартів
та корпоративних принципів, повертаючи Україну до управління в ручному режимі.
Я особисто був здивований недавніми змінами у керівництві "Нафтогазу".
Ідеться не про персоналії, а про те, як це було зроблено.
І це насправді не виглядало як дії згідно з кращими практиками корпоративного управління.
Подібні речі відбуваються в Україні. Тож, я б закликав президента та всю урядову команду
більше слідувати європейським стандартам у процесі ухвалення рішень.
Опитані DW європейські політики, підсумовуючи два роки президентства Зеленського,
кажуть, що дива, на жаль, не сталося. Але це, мовляв, типово для таких країн, як Україна.
Литва та інші держави колишнього соцтабору теж проходили непростий період трансформацій,
і не все виходило одразу. Серед досягнень Зеленського у ЄС називають земельну реформу,
яку вважають історичним рішенням, що дасть добре підґрунтя для розвитку країни.
Крім того, плюсом у президентському балансі Зеленського у Брюсселі вважають
цифровізацію державних послуг, продовження реформи у регіональній політиці,
передусім децентралізацію, а також боротьбу з пропагандою і дезінформацією,
як-от закриття трьох телеканалів, пов’язаних з кумом Путіна Віктором Медведчуком.
Зважаючи на європейські цінності, з одного боку, ми розуміємо потребу України захищати себе.
І ЄС має робити більше, щоб допомогти Україні бути готовою до гібридної війни з боку Росії,
в якій би формі це не було.
Але з іншого боку, треба також поважати принципи свободи слова, свободи преси.
Провали ж, на які вказують західні політики та експерти, залишаються незмінними.
Передусім це судова реформа і реальна, а не декларативна боротьба з корупцією та впливом олігархів.
Оголошення підозри у держзраді та домашній арешт Віктора Медведчука
у Брюсселі коментують обережно, натякаючи, що є ще інші олігархи
і всі мають бути рівними перед законом.
А боротьба з корупцією має зачіпати не лише обраних, а кожного, якщо на це є підстави.